This is Jocko podcast number 42 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Now in podcast number 11 we brought on Leif Babin,
who was the Charlie platoon commander.
Charlie between was a part of task unit bruiser.
Obviously Lafe is one of my brothers guy wrote the book extreme ownership with,
so
that's leaf Charlie platoon.
And when,
when he was on that first podcast,
we talked about a bunch of things,
but one of the main focuses of our conversation was some of the brothers that we
lost.
Mark Lee,
who was the first seal killed in Iraq.
We talked about big goals.
Ryan job,
who was gravely wounded in Ramadi and who later died after complications from a
surgery to repair those wounds.
And finally we talked about Chris Kyle,
who was also in Charlie platoon,
was the lead sniper and point man and who ended up writing the book,
American sniper,
which was,
you know,
turned into a very successful movie.
And Chris,
as you know,
was senselessly murdered as he tried to help out a fellow veteran.
And on that podcast,
we didn't talk in any depth at all about Mikey monster,
who is another one of our brothers seals from task unit bruiser who was also
killed in Ramadi.
And if you don't know,
Mikey was posthumously awarded the medal of honor after he smothered a grenade
with his body in order to save three of our other teammates
in.
One of the reasons I didn't want to focus on Mikey during that podcast is
because Mikey was in Delta platoon as opposed to Charlie between chocolatiers
two platoons in the task unit,
Charlie and Delta and Charlie was Lafe was the platoon commander and Tony,
uh,
fratty who was on the podcast as well,
he was the the platoon chief.
And before I went and talked about Mikey,
I wanted to bring somebody from Delta platoon on the podcast.
It's a little bit trickier than it sounds because most of the guys from Delta
platoon are still active duty and the ones that aren't active duty are,
they're not around.
I couldn't get get ahold of them or if I get ahold of them,
they,
they were busy are I?
They were out of the area.
So it's just been hard.
It's been a challenge.
But I didn't want to wait.
And finally,
and we're lucky because
I got one of my,
one of my good Bros here,
guy by the name of Andrew Paul,
who was the assistant platoon commander in Delta platoon tasking at bruiser seal
team three.
But I wanted to start off today by reading a speech that I gave at one of the
ceremonies that took place when Mikey was awarded the medal of honor.
And this was not the ceremony that took place at the White House with President
Bush,
which actually the entirety of tasking at bruiser did attend that and it was
awesome.
But I gave this speech at a navy ceremony that took place.
I think it took place later in the day or perhaps the next day at the navy
memorial in Washington DC.
And that day there was a ton of senior naval officers in attendance and
basically the whole of the seniority of,
of the,
of the navy was there,
you know,
this,
the chief of naval operations and the secretary of the navy.
And there was a bunch of other metal of honor winners there,
including a couple other seal metal of honor winners.
They knew it was a
very fitting day and it was a great honor for me to be able to give this speech
and here it is.
Okay.
Yeah.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it is obviously very humbling to be here today as it was humbling to be on the
battlefield of Ramadi with my fellow seals
and the two to eight brigade combat team,
the iron soldiers,
and then the one one d,
The ready first combat team,
which was a formed up by our brothers from the army,
navy,
air force and Marines.
And it included such hallowed units as the first two,
the five oh six band of brothers,
the one three seven bandits and the three eight marines.
I met Mike Monster when he checked into seal team three as a new,
highly motivated young frogman
as we trained and prepared to deploy to Iraq,
everyone learned that Mike was an incredible person.
He was gifted in everything he did.
Hardworking,
funny,
and selfless.
Okay.
He was the ultimate teammate.
The ultimate friend.
When Mike died,
a picture of him circulated in the news.
It showed Mike and his platoon mates and the war torn streets of Ramadi shrouded
in a midst of greenish yellow smoke,
which was used to mask their movement from the enemy.
That picture says so much.
Mike's gun is at the ready.
His face,
his calm,
almost smiling despite the obvious chaos and danger around him.
Ramadi at the time was the epicenter of the insurgency in Iraq.
A city filled with peril.
The hardened to enemy was bent on destruction.
They fought with ruthlessness constantly on the attack with machine guns,
mortars,
grenades,
and I eds.
Okay.
Brave men died or wounded every day and every day brave man continued to push
forward into the fray
for those of us who were there.
That picture of Mike captures all of this in the picture.
His brother seals are nearby,
but Mikey is out front.
I have looked at this picture over and over again and it speaks to me
as someone that had the pleasure of knowing Mike.
He is a friend and had the honor of serving with him on the battlefield.
This photograph tells me a story.
As I look at that picture,
I hear a voice in a humble but confident tone.
This voice says to me,
I am Michael Monsoor.
I am patrolling through the streets of Ramadi.
It is a city devastated by war.
Bullet holes cover the rubber rebel.
The buildings burned out.
Cars littered the streets.
I am walking just behind my point,
man.
I am ready.
My eyes sting from the sweat my gun and gear our heavy,
but these things do not bother me.
There is no comfort here,
but this is the life I have chosen and there is no other place.
I would rather be.
I am Michael [inaudible] sore.
I pray and I believe my faith is my shelter.
My faith is my strength.
Fear thrives in this place,
but fear is no match for my faith.
Faith conquers all.
The word of the Lord proves true.
He is a shield for all those who take refuge in him.
Lord,
protect my brothers above all else you have made me ready to protect them.
I am Michael [inaudible] sore.
I am far away from home.
I miss my family.
I miss my mother,
my father,
my sister and brothers.
Everything I am is rooted in them.
I want to hold my nephews and nieces again.
I want to make them smile and laugh,
but I am far away from home.
Instead,
I smile at the Iraqi children where we passed them by.
When we encounter Iraqi families,
I treat them with respect and dignity.
I know the importance of family because there was nothing more important to me
than my family.
Okay.
I am Michael [inaudible].
I love my country.
My fellow seals and the men,
men fighting alongside us.
The men fighting alongside us and the streets are infantry,
men,
grunts.
I know these grants are not just soldiers and marines,
but fathers and brothers and sons.
I know because my father and brother were also grunts,
proud marine rifleman.
We are fighting are determined enemy,
but we are strong.
Our strength is our brotherhood.
Soldiers,
sailors,
airmen and Marines fighting together a brotherhood,
bound by sweat and blood and tears.
Together we live in dust and dirt and filth
and death.
Death is everywhere.
Many of my brothers have fallen.
Mark.
He is gone.
But we fight on for,
for the men to our left and right.
We fight on,
I am so proud to be part of this band of brothers.
I am Michael Months Sore.
I am ready forged by faith and family molded by belief and brotherhood.
I have live life to its fullest.
I have not looked back.
I leave nothing but love
and I have no regrets.
Okay.
I am Michael [inaudible].
I am the frog man on the high ground
and I have given everything for you.
And that was the speech
and I did my best to
share my thoughts about marquis,
then a monitor year to
Andrew Paul with me today.
Like I said,
the former assistant platoon commander from Delta platoon
to share some stories about Ramadi and about Mikey and about tasking at bruiser
and about himself and the lessons that he learned over there.
Yeah.
And how he carried those lessons to civilian life and the kind of challenges he
faced there.
So
Andrew,
Paul,
my brother,
welcome to the show.
Thanks for coming on.
Thanks for having me Bro.
It's an honor to be here.
And you know,
the main thing,
listening to that speech,
I remember when you gave it my hope and prayer today is that whatever I do here
today,
it honors is a legacy of our brothers.
Absolutely.
And we'll get,
we'll get into plenty of that.
But in order,
and I hate to do this because everybody does this.
When they start like this type of situation,
it's almost like a bar or a pickup line,
you know?
Hey,
we're so where are you from?
Right?
So,
uh,
that being said,
Andrew,
so where are you from?
Where am I from?
I'm from New England,
New Hampshire.
We at Tony's.
Tony was just on,
you know,
the New England death.
That's right.
If I don't get some boys from Texas on here,
I'm going to get,
I'm going to help me to start hearing about it.
You gotta be real hard to grow up in New England.
Let me tell you,
it's cold.
True.
So,
so you grew up in New England and,
and by the way,
for those of you that just listening on the podcast,
what do you weigh?
155.
One 55.
So the,
the,
the image that everyone has,
if the big navy seal is not,
first of all,
it's not true.
They're seals come in every shape and every size and Andrew comes in the smaller
size.
And,
uh,
so,
but how did you,
uh,
so,
so wait,
did you,
how did you ever,
how'd you hear about the seals?
Like what made you decide that that was what you wanted to do?
Yeah.
You know,
I'm,
first of all,
I've always been the kind of person that like,
tell me I can't do something and I'm going to just show you.
So I mean things like,
oh,
we're in high school and someone says we're talking about like the Boston
Marathon.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to run.
you can't do that marathon.
Oh,
okay.
Watch this.
Ran the Boston marathon.
Um,
but you know,
okay.
Probably saw a movie.
Cause you know,
when I was growing up,
there wasn't a lot of information out there about the seal teams.
And so tell me about it,
right?
I mean,
even less for an old guy like you.
Um,
so there wasn't a lot of information,
but somehow you probably saw a movie,
ended up reading a book and then,
you know,
started to do some research and found,
well,
first of all,
outside my immediate family,
um,
uncles,
grandfather,
all served in the military.
So I grew up with that song,
strong sense of wanting to serve my country and uh,
always had a sense of one to protect people who couldn't themselves.
So it
was drawn to that kind of line of work.
Then began to read about the seal teams,
and at least from what information I had available,
it seemed like,
hey,
they were the best.
So I'm like,
all right,
well if that's the best and that's what I want to go do,
hey,
that was it.
You know,
that was in its infancy as it,
as a young kid.
But then,
man,
I just got on to that like a bulldog,
bulldog on a pork chop and just,
I mean,
oh,
tunnel vision went after it and you get you,
did you go to college?
Did you already have that decision in your mind when you went to college?
Oh yeah.
So you knew you're going to go to ocs,
you knew all that.
Did you know ROTC?
I did ROTC.
So the thing is is that I didn't know,
I didn't know anything.
I mean,
I didn't know about,
I didn't even know what ROTC was.
I didn't even know what enlisting was.
I had no clue.
No would,
no,
no exposure.
I just knew I wanted to be a seal.
So,
you know,
but we start looking at going to college and I went down and I looked at
Vanderbilt University among others,
John Hopkins or Rpi goes an engineering major and I knew nothing.
And all of a sudden I walk into this almost like job fair kind of style thing.
Like welcome,
check out the school.
And there's this guy in uniform.
And he's of course got a picture of like some navy seal frogmen coming out of
the water over the beach.
And I was like,
Hey,
what's this realistic picture of all time,
right?
Because that's what we do every day.
And like,
Hey,
what's this?
He goes,
oh,
well this is our two sigma would say,
oh well you go to college,
we pay for college.
And then you go in the navy and I'm like,
wait,
you can be a seal through this program.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Big Lie.
Like they take like 16 guys a year.
Oh yeah,
you can be a seal.
Oh,
okay.
Wait,
let me get this straight.
So I go to college,
you pay for it,
watch this.
I get to go in the navy and I can be a seal.
Yup.
I'm like,
sign me up.
So that's how I found out about ROTC recruiter.
Just straight truth from the recruiter.
You got to love it.
That's right.
Yes,
you can be a seal.
It's a little did I know.
So you get done with college,
get your commission,
you do ROTC and then you go to,
you go to buds show up to buds.
That was funny.
I showed up.
So I asked the ROTC instructor,
Hey,
um,
you know,
like what's the process for checking in?
Do I just like,
what should I wear?
I would just wear,
you know,
appropriate civilian attire.
So I show up to the buds quarter deck and like a collared shirt walking out of
the quarter deck and one of the most sadistic instructors possible happen to be
standing there.
I walk on,
I'm like,
Hey,
uh,
I'm here to check in.
Like,
like the all seeing eye,
just like glance is like you said what?
I was up checking into buds wearing that.
I'm like,
uh,
maybe I should go put it in four months.
Yeah,
good idea.
Run out to my car.
Three minutes.
And your uniform son,
right?
Went on,
put on my sdbs,
came back promptly,
got wet and Sandy,
that's how it works as dbs because you don't know,
it's like the Ah,
the high level uniform with all the ribbons and all that crap on it.
And then you got to,
you know,
you've got to take good care of it.
So when you take that and you wear it down to the ocean and then you jump in the
ocean and roll around in the sand,
it's not a good deal.
So that'll inform.
The good news is there weren't a lot of ribbons on there yet.
So we had one ribbon,
so,
and you end up going through buds with leaf,
right.
Which people know who Lafe is obviously.
Um,
which is cool.
And then you get done with buds.
Any,
I mean,
buds,
buds.
I don't really care about buds.
Yeah.
Some funny life stories.
So I talked about my bro.
I got pneumonia in hell week,
first time through.
So I got rolled back and start over.
So,
um,
and then,
and then later transferred in.
So Lafe was our,
was our class leader.
And so me,
the Delta platoon commander,
who one day you'll hear from,
uh,
and he and I,
we all went through buds together,
but they were both lateral transfers in.
So they were senior to me in rank right there already,
like JG and the in a full lieutenant and a,
so there's games in Bud's,
right?
Like you're,
you're trying to win.
So,
you know,
we were,
we were wise to the game's already to try and win in life if,
you know,
my brother is like,
life is black and white with my brother late.
Okay.
So I'm going to hear about this one,
but he,
so you know,
it's right and it's wrong.
And there's like,
and so we know,
we're like,
you know,
bud,
sort of like,
if you ain't cheating,
you ain't trying.
And if you get caught,
she ain't trying hard enough.
I mean,
so,
and there's an element of that and buds,
uh,
obviously not completely,
but so,
you know,
we're,
we're pulling all kinds of games and in his book,
who is losing,
because we are just,
we're cheating to win.
And he's getting so pissed like after the race,
like after class he's like,
hey you got,
and then he finally wasn't up and started playing the game.
That thing about you ain't,
you can try and that sort of,
that's sort of one side of buds.
And what was cool was when I went through buds,
they actually told us like these couple of instructors were,
were like,
listen,
that's a little saying it's not true.
They actually said if you're cheating,
you're cheating yourself.
Right.
Which I was.
And then obviously then they start saying,
look,
if you've got guys that are cheating here to get through this training,
you don't really want them in the teams with,
you know,
I don't want a guy that that it has to cheat to,
to complete a run or a swim negative.
Yeah.
I mean that there's difference between like cheating,
like cutting off the run versus like you're in competition,
you're not going to other guy,
whatever,
you know,
competing,
hitting a guy in the face of the paddle,
just that type of thing.
Right.
So you get done.
So you get done because you were a junior.
When you get to the tee,
you went rights team three,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
So you get to team three,
but you don't get to go on deployment with team three.
They cook you up with being a boat unit commander.
Yeah.
So no one's gonna know what that is.
All right.
So,
so the deal was,
and this is changes throughout the years,
but like when I checked into team three,
there was this brief period of time where it was in charge at the time.
Decided that third,
Oh is in a platoon was a bad idea for officer development,
says no more third [inaudible].
So basically I was faced with being a talk jockey or going over to the boat team
and at least being in charge of something to get some leadership experience.
So I went over to the special boat teams,
which is part of naval special warfare.
And ultimately when they deploy the deploy as part of the task unit and,
or the task group,
and it's all integrated and part of,
you know,
visit board search and seizure maritime operations such as,
uh,
leadership,
interdiction,
maritime interdiction operations.
And so the boat unit,
which is special boat teams,
is run essentially at the,
at the leadership level by seals.
So the commanding officer of the boat unit,
the executive officers are,
are seals the boat.
That OIC is the mark fives all,
we don't have mark fives anymore.
Um,
our,
our seal officers.
So look as a brand new officer,
at least had an opportunity to deploy in a,
in a combat zone to lead men and,
and to work with my seal brothers who were conducting operations in the northern
rubion golf.
Yeah.
And just an overview,
I'm just going to sum this up as quickly as I can.
So obviously seals work on water a lot and we,
we drive our own little bullets,
our own little,
you know,
12 foot Zodiac boats with 55 horsepower motors on them,
or 35 horsepower motors on them or whatever.
But the bigger boats,
we don't,
we don't drive those.
So anything,
you know,
you see any of those bigger bullets are,
are driven by these guys that are called,
they're now called sweat special warfare combatant crewman,
which are guys that,
that's what they do.
Their boat drivers.
So,
and they do,
they insert,
extract us,
you know,
drop there,
dropped their boats out of various aircraft.
It's so it's,
it's a legit job and they,
and that's what they do.
And so you were in charge of uh,
a group of those guys took boats on deployment to the Arabian Gulf and did what
you did over there.
Right.
The reality is,
is not the,
it's not the dream for the seal young seal officer to be that,
to do that.
But it's a good,
like you said,
it's good.
All of a sudden you're in charge of something real.
You know when you're out in the water.
And I'd tell people,
I used to tell people this when I was in the teams,
I say,
listen,
when you're on the water,
it's a real world op.
Cause.
Cause if something goes wrong when you're in the water,
I mean first of all,
you can drown.
You could and that's,
and you can get lost.
There's all kinds of bad things that happened.
So if you don't plan right on the water,
it doesn't matter if there's an enemy or not.
You got a big giant enemy,
it's called the ocean and they will kill you if you're not squared away.
And I think actually that's one of the things that make seals good is that we
work in the water and the water's one of the toughest enemies.
You can come up with one forgive.
It's unforgiving.
Yeah.
So that wraps up that you come home from that deployment.
Yep.
And now you are still in seal team three or you go back to seal team three I
guess technically.
Yeah.
And now we form up and you become the Delta platoon assistant platoon commander
checking in.
Awesome.
Working for the Delta platoon commander.
Who you,
you guys were [inaudible] we're bros.
Yeah.
We've known each other for years.
Went through buds together and Lafe.
So you guys must've been pretty stoked on that.
It was cool.
It was kind of like get the band back together and you know,
and those,
and look,
those two guys had just come off of not the greatest appointments either in
terms of the junior officer seal.
Right.
Because they were deployed and they were the assistant commanders and they were
getting stuck with not so fun work.
Right.
You know,
so we were stoked to be all right.
They were soaked like hey now we're the OIC.
We're not going to be the guy stuck back
doing the paperwork and we were getting the band back together and then when we
found out you are our task unit commander,
it was like,
oh cause we,
we all knew we were going to be in the platoon together and tasks you and
together we didn't know who RTU commander was going to be yet.
And then we were all those rumor rumor who were going to get,
and then we heard this Guy Jocko was coming over you who I was,
I only knew who you were through them.
Like when other guys like said,
oh Jocko,
bad ass to do this is going to be awesome.
Right.
Because like we already had an inkling that like if,
if this dude was going to be or to commander,
we had our best shot at getting it in combat.
Although we had no idea what was about to happen.
Good assessment.
Yeah.
Your reputation,
your reputation was great,
but you were coming over in that case for being the admiral's sales coming from
being the animals.
Yup.
13 months with,
uh,
with the admiral,
which was a,
uh,
a rough tour in terms of things that normal seal,
same thing,
right?
Like to do,
that's right.
And I,
and,
and you know,
for instance,
I mean,
just,
just straight up wearing a uniform every single day.
Which zoo,
so people don't,
so people understand in the world when,
and I don't know what it's like this moment today when I was in the teams,
when I was at seal team,
one seal team to seal teams,
we,
I didn't wear a shirt,
right?
No.
I'm a 35 year old man making money,
doing it with a family.
I'm not wearing a shirt at work,
like,
Oh,
I'm in my office call,
I'm not wearing a shirt,
I'm wearing shorts and a pair of jungle boots.
Right?
That's it.
So I do that for my whole life,
right?
Since I was a kid,
since I was like 19 year old kid when I got through,
boom.
So I now I go to be the admiral's aid and I have to wear a uniform every day,
not just one uniform.
I have to wear Khakis,
then whites,
then blues.
And you're just in this constant uniform.
And,
and seals are not good about uniforms.
They just,
they're just not,
it's not one of our strong points.
And so,
so that's one of the things that made the job,
not very fun,
but there's a good lesson there,
right?
So here,
I mean,
everybody knows you as an incredible leader,
awesome seal.
And yet for this period of time you had to do this job that was not particularly
fun.
It's kind of like,
you know,
I had to go over and be the seal at the boat unit.
Right?
But do life is full of things like that.
And when you are part of the team,
no matter what you do it to the best of your ability.
And you did an awesome job is the admiral's aid,
not necessarily what you wanted to do,
being a trident where in frog.
So I got an email from one of the assistant platoon commanders in Charlie
platoon a year ago and he said,
hey bro,
I'm going to go be the aid.
Yeah,
talking to me.
And so I just saw him and he was laughing.
He goes,
your email back to me,
you said this is going to be very hard for you because you're not good at this
kind of thing.
And I was pretty good at it,
so you're going to have to work extra hard to make this happen.
And he was laughing.
We were both laughing because you know what I'm talking about it.
He's not a guy that is all over the,
the,
the minutiae.
Of course he did a great job because he stepped up his game.
But yeah,
when you get a task with something,
you do it and you do it the best of your ability.
And,
and you know,
just to continue that story,
cause I have to say this,
it was a,
it was a pain in the ass job.
It wasn't fun for me,
but man,
did I learn a lot?
Did I understand a lot?
Did I get to know all the inner workings of,
of the community because I was there with the guy,
you know,
with the animal that was in charge of all the seals.
I was with him for 13 months.
I mean all day travel,
w you know,
wake up PT.
We were just,
I every meeting,
you know,
so it was a,
it was a great learning experience for me and I was appreciative and he was a
great guy.
He's a great guy and he really cared about the seal platoons.
So,
which is,
which is awesome when a guy puts the number one priority,
he'd always talk about,
okay,
what's,
what's the seal platoon need?
Or how does this affect the seal platoon?
Yep.
So then we got in,
but now you're in your first workup,
right?
Going through workup,
getting,
getting your game on.
Awesome.
Best time of my life.
Yeah.
Anybody who's in the military right now and active duty teams,
if you're listening to this demand,
just enjoy it,
man.
Enjoy it.
I mean there's other things in life.
Sure.
But like you can,
you just,
you can't replace that time it and there's stupid stuff you deal with.
Yes.
But trust me,
enjoy this man.
You won't find anywhere else.
Nothing like that.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Do you,
what do you I would talk about this sometimes.
So one of the scars that you get from the military,
from the seal teams is if you go,
if you like to shoot weapons still.
Oh yeah.
And you want to go shooting,
you have to pay for ammunition.
There's an expensive and,
and I'm serious.
I remember times in the seal teams where,
I mean your,
your thumbs are getting,
your funds are literally getting sore from reloading magazines for days and
days.
You're shooting all the,
all the bullets you could possibly ever,
ever,
ever want to shoot ever.
You're going to shoot them all in a week or two weeks.
And so it's,
it's so fun.
It's so fun.
And you know for us,
and for those of you that don't know,
so you go through a workup prior to going on deployment,
which is now you're working together for the first time.
This is when I'm getting to know you guys.
You guys are getting to know me.
We're all getting to know each other,
where the whole,
the whole unit is coming together as a team and this is where the real bond
forms and you're doing super hard training.
You're,
you're living together,
you're working out together,
you're working together,
you're partying together,
you're eating your meals together.
It's just a 24 seven rock and roll awesomeness.
And then that's how,
that's how it,
that's how you get to know these guys.
That's how you get to know your,
your,
your team.
Yup.
So me,
Mikey and another guy were the knee or the new guys and Netflix and one other
guy.
He saw an active duty.
Yeah.
No,
I'm just saying there was only three new guys in Appleton.
Yeah.
Dang,
I forgot about that.
Yeah.
In our,
in,
in Delta and Delta.
Yeah.
Needless to say,
Delta and Charlie were slightly different dynamic.
Yeah.
You guys were,
you guys are a different dynamic.
A different,
just like people have different personalities,
full tunes have different personalities and teams have different personalities
and they can morph and change.
But nonetheless,
uh,
both grateful tombs,
both your platoon.
Oh yeah.
It's,
it was only you and Mikey and one other guy.
I know who the other guy was.
Yeah.
The tick,
you guys were the only three new guys in there.
Yup.
So it can be a harsh,
it's,
it's a harsh environment to come into when you're,
when you're a new guy in a seal platoon.
But,
so I'm with,
so I'm with Mikey and we're doing,
we're just,
I don't even think we're doing mobility,
but we are driving out to the ranges and he's the,
uh,
he's the Turret gunner,
right.
And
I say something to them like,
Hey,
when we're approaching a road,
you know,
you look at your field of fire and if there's no vehicles coming,
say clear.
Right?
And so he,
he did it once and he's clear,
clear,
right.
You know,
kind of quiet and I was like,
hey man,
you got to sound off the drivers try to drive.
He's got it.
He's got radio on and he's,
he needs to know what's going on,
man.
You need to sound off.
Yeah.
And the next row intersection we've got to,
he's like clue.
Right.
And he said it super loud and I thought to myself,
wait a second,
is he,
you know,
taking the piss out of me as he,
is he being sarcastic with that yell,
right?
No and no.
He was not.
No.
I told him to yell,
but he was like,
okay,
I will yell.
And that's,
that's the way it worked.
The other,
one of my other favorite stories about Mikey was,
and this is another like new guy related story,
was,
so you go through CQC training,
close quarter combat,
close quarter battle,
whatever.
It's basically shooting in small spaces,
taking down buildings,
that kind of thing.
And it's,
it's a,
there's,
there's a lot of instructor focus on the mechanics of what you're doing.
So it's a very,
it's a very mechanical thing.
And if you,
if you're making mistakes,
it's not going to work out good for you.
And by the way,
as a new guy,
there's tough scrutiny.
But the reality is it doesn't matter if you're new or not.
Like they were watching everybody,
but he's getting watched.
You can be a third platoon guy and get canned from the platoon for a safety
violation and you'll get a safety violation in two seconds.
He's not there and in a half a second.
Yeah,
it doesn't take much.
So,
and what they're trying to do is they're trying to put more stress on you,
right?
Because they want to,
they want you to handle the stress.
So they stressed people out by just,
you know,
these little minute details of what you could do right and wrong.
And to be honest with you,
some of them don't matter.
Some of them you're like,
okay,
that doesn't matter you and,
and,
and I know they don't matter cause they,
they morph over time and they'll teach you one s phase.
There'll be teaching one thing and then later they'll teach the phase,
they'll teach another thing and then later they'll teach another thing.
So
it's not,
there's a million different ways to do it.
Yeah.
And you could argue this one's better,
but there's a million different ways to do it.
But they do,
they pick whatever they're going to choose for.
That block of training is what you're going to do.
And,
and if you want to sit there and argue with them,
oh boy is not going to work out good for you.
So what?
I told all the new guys and Delta and Charlotte too,
and I said,
well,
hey,
listen,
when the instructor cadre is telling you to do something or they're yelling at
you or they're getting on your ass about something,
you just look at him and say,
Roger,
that guy's got it.
Roger that.
And these guys were like,
And that's the best attitude you want to have,
right?
Because what you want,
what do you want to be a new guy that's like,
hey,
no,
I don't agree with your tactics.
They're a person that's deployed,
you know,
oversees 14 times.
No you don't want to be that guy.
You might think you're right but no,
this is what you know,
that's not what you want to do.
So I told the guys,
say Roger that.
So we're going through the training,
the training is great and we're doing really well.
Our tasking,
it's doing great,
you know,
but still guys are guys are making mistakes,
whatever.
And finally the master chief and of course for like Tony and I were friends with
all the cadre guys cause they're all our bros from being in teams.
And one of the the leader guy,
he comes up to me and he's like,
hey,
he's hard.
But it was these guys.
He goes,
hey,
what's up with this guy Monae store?
And I was like,
auto,
what do you mean,
what's up?
He said,
he's been doing a good job.
What's up?
He goes,
every time I tell him something,
all he does is to just look at me and say Roger that.
And I go,
hey brother,
you know what?
He's doing exactly what I told him to do.
I literally told him,
the only thing I wanted wanted him to say to you guys are wanting any of the new
guys to say to you guys was Roger that and make it happen.
So when we were out there,
there was another platoon that was there at the same time.
Do you remember this?
They were,
and,
and I,
I'm pretty sure the chief got canned from the platoon he safety violation.
And there was some,
and there was that talking back going on,
right?
Like,
Hey,
I've got three deployments under my belt.
And you know,
there's a degree of humility in that Roger,
that response,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's Roger that I'm open to the correction you have for me.
Yeah,
for sure.
And so,
and these guys,
him and there's a balance there.
I mean,
he's leading his platoon and taking a stand for,
you know,
and being in charge,
but at the same time,
like there's a humility and a respect in that response.
And he was not doing that.
And I'm telling you like,
he screwed some things up and they safety review board.
I mean I'm going to have a holding a safety review board for the chief of that
platoon.
It was not our task unit [inaudible] they do not play around.
No.
And,
and that's the way it's supposed to be because it's intense and when people
don't get is that you're trying to recreate the intensity of combat as best as
you can.
So they're creating high stress situations as stressful as possible.
And like you said,
sometimes creating elements that aren't necessarily real,
but just to overload you with a number of things you have to process under
pressure and then are you going to make good decisions under pressure?
And that right there is what translates to combat good decisions under stress
and under.
Yeah.
And you're right though about that humility piece and that was our attitude
going through.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Between me and Tony,
I don't think there was,
I'm just trying to think if there's any instructor cadre that was putting us
through.
Right.
There were some guys that were,
but there was,
it wasn't like there was someone that was just,
you know,
had tons more experience.
And then the two of us.
And yet we,
you know,
both Tony and Roger that,
yeah,
hey,
it sounds good.
We'll,
we'll make that adjustment because you know what,
it's great just having Tony on the other day.
He was just saying,
look,
you can,
I'm learning something new all the time,
learning something from the new guys.
And that's the attitude that prevailed through the task unit.
Not of,
Hey,
we're the best.
We don't have to listen to me buddy,
but hey,
we're going to work as hard as we can.
We're going to be the best we can,
but we're,
we had open minds and we're ready to learn at all times.
It's a fine line between confident and cocky,
no doubt about that.
And being humble,
you can be confident.
You can be sure.
And you can be humble and respectful and open to learning new things and may be
surprised at what you learn.
Yeah,
there's no doubt about that.
So what else do you remember from workup in terms of,
hey,
you're a new guy,
you're checking in.
You know,
Tony and I told some stories of what it was like when we were checking into team
won.
It was when we were new guys.
It was a very rough environment to roll it into.
Yeah.
What did you think when you got to,
you know,
being a new guy?
Well,
I remember like literally day,
first of all day one that I was checking into the platoons space.
I got like the Combo to the platoon space,
right?
And I went in and I'm me,
I'm brand new and a so I'm going to be protective of my platoon,
you know.
So I go in,
I'm walking out of the platoon space,
making sure the door is locked behind me cause you know,
other platoon Kaz go in and just destroy it.
Other guys,
platoon in space or whatever.
And I'm walking down the hallway and um,
our LPO,
who is,
goes down to the door and he doesn't have the Combo,
right.
And he goes,
he goes,
hey,
what's the combo to the space?
I'm like,
I gave him some,
why is astronaut not know him?
No,
didn't know him yet.
Right.
How'd that work out for you?
It was hilarious.
Like he,
he,
he goes,
hey,
what's the combo to the space?
I'm like,
hey man,
I can't give that to you.
And then I didn't know is the LPO.
And he's like,
he goes,
he goes on the Goddamn Lpl.
What's the fucking Combo to the Muldoon space?
Like Roger,
that three,
three one together then to,
you know,
and I'll proceed to walk down the steps.
Oh God.
All Mighty.
I am just,
I just met the LPO and it was not on good terms.
Oh man,
that's awesome.
He and I turned out to be good friends,
but um,
I remember were out doing land warfare training and this is like where,
you know,
you're cutting the metal,
like you said,
you're getting to know each other and you know,
the guys in the platoon also trying to figure out what these new guys like.
All right,
what have I,
what have we got here?
What can we rely on,
you know?
And uh,
so one night I remember us doing a little bit of boxing and it was forced
boxing,
new guy on new guy.
You know,
and a survival of the fittest it.
And then at times it was just three on,
you know,
every man for himself.
And it's just like your head's on a swivel and it's Mikey the tick and me and
we're just whaling away and it's just going and it's,
hey,
who's going to continue to fight basically,
right.
And everything,
you know,
I'm an officer and these two guys are just,
obviously we'll in a way,
but I'm like,
hey man,
I'm going to just fight to the bitter end.
And it was,
it was pretty awesome.
Hey,
did you do Jujitsu before you got you had just enough?
I didn't make it that you could hold your own.
I would when I would do the officer Coumadin.
Yes,
I did do some.
And you know,
to keep in mind,
did you train on the east coast?
When I was in high school and I got in,
I got into Gracie Jujitsu,
like literally like I was already training when the first UFC ever made.
Right.
And so it was pretty cool.
And then that was always a big shocker for people because you were,
you are by far smaller than the other platoon officers and yet you had that
Jujitsu,
Jujitsu.
When you have the Jujitsu,
you didn't have a lot either,
won't know.
Even a blue belt,
I don't even know.
You were probably like a high level white belt.
But,
but to be fair,
like at the time it was all very new.
Like the world of MMA today is totally different.
Totally different as you know.
But at the time,
like,
I mean I even went to in high school with my,
with my instructor who was that,
who was a teacher at my school.
He was into it.
So he and I would train like five in the morning before school.
Me versus him,
much larger men,
but we learned to just to,
and then we went in and did seminars with hoists,
Gracie,
um,
in upstate New York we would drive.
And uh,
it was cool.
Like I got to get out of school.
And again,
this is just proof that you just see so good because he would,
I would make these,
these officers,
like we meet at five o'clock in the morning and I'd say,
okay,
and I would train with everybody,
but then I'd say,
okay,
now you,
you to,
to fight to the death.
And they would just get after it.
But,
but he was,
he was 150 pounds.
He's going against guys that are 200 pounds,
you know,
they haven't by 50 pounds and taller than me and taller and,
and he would just,
you know,
there's,
it just doesn't work.
You know,
you gotta,
you gotta know that you did sue.
Yeah.
And I'm not going to,
I'm not going to say that I wailed and these are tough guys drive though.
That's right.
Like they weren't tapping me out,
you know,
then you usually tap them.
I usually choked out a certain guy who didn't like that very much.
It's a hard,
it's all,
it's,
it's a humbling thing,
but you know,
and,
and the thing at that time,
because they are bigger than me,
was more about energy conservation.
Right.
And so like,
I mean,
I'd just let them wear themselves out and then they try and get things on me and
then I'd just sneak my way around there.
Buddy.
Also remember you volunteering for the taste.
So I actually had an attitude like you had it,
you look like I can here,
I'm going to handle this.
Like no factor.
What you want to tase me,
bring it.
That's right.
You'll know you don't see the guys on the cops.
When is big,
tough,
crazy guy all on PCP and he gets Tazy rips the Taser out and throws the thing
and he just keeps coming.
That's what Andrew Paul had the look like.
I'm gonna go,
you're gonna tase me.
Bring it,
let's go.
I mean,
Hey,
I'm a new guy in the platoon,
right?
I mean,
I've got to earn my spot.
Right?
And so somewhere somebody had,
actually,
it was the Lpo he had,
he had one of these things and I was like,
oh,
I'm going to tell you what,
like it had these like two modes and one where you could shoot or you could like
put it right up to the guy,
you know?
And I was like,
Hey,
let's go shoot him.
Be like,
really?
I'm like,
come on,
let's go.
And then like throw platoon,
like everybody like met down in the bat cave and um,
there may be a video floating around somewhere.
This one had the winter barbs at those.
He doesn't know what a Taser is,
like the Bar,
the winter barbs or longer to get through the sweater.
Who that down coat.
Yeah.
And um,
so when of course he was like,
what were you in a t shirt or just no shirt.
I was in a tee shirt.
Yeah.
And uh,
I was like,
oh,
those are winter Barb's work out for you.
So it's like,
there's like,
oh,
they're getting ready to do it.
They're like,
oh wait,
wait.
And you know,
these are my guys looking out for me.
I appreciate it guys.
They're like,
oh wait here put this I pro on,
oh that's a good idea.
Right.
So puts them on a pro on and then like,
like it's got a laser on it.
Right?
So the laser,
I mean if you seen the video like,
like you hear guys going like guys or wincing like nobody's been tastes like
nobody knows what's going to happen right now.
Right.
Boom.
So this thing comes out at like 45 degree angle in one like goes into my sternum
and the other one goes below my belly button.
So I'm like instantly over all that thinking he was just going to rip those six
out.
He went ridge and thank God we put a mat down cause he went rigid straight and
fell like a brick boom.
Nothing.
And it just so it so clearly,
and I remember this too,
like it hits you and hits you in that,
in that spot and like your hands go to like you've been stung,
you'd been hit.
So you my hands,
my hands get like three quarters of the way there.
By the time the electricity freezes the body.
So my hands are kind of like stuck in front of my chest and my admin as it
attempted to grab the spot.
So I go over and um,
all right.
They'd turn the thing off and then,
um,
they go to get these things out.
Somebody got a pair of pliers and,
and the Barb,
I remember that good with you need to dislodge them.
So like you went into the muscle like,
because like I remember ripping and coming free but not free.
And it was,
but it was still beneath the skin and uh,
and then it just like,
just rip it.
This is the team's Bam.
This is what makes the team so fun.
Yeah.
One day you show up at work,
you use volunteer to get tased and you're going to get some,
the best thing you can do is just volunteer in a situation like that,
you know?
And just be like,
come on,
let's go.
Yup.
Brilliant.
And then they go,
oh,
okay.
Right on.
You know?
Yeah.
Well you did
the right thing.
I'm sorry it didn't work out too well.
I think it worked out great.
All right.
So we get word we'd get done with our work up and now it's time to go on
deployment and um,
get on to the limit.
And we found out what,
two weeks before you guys were on leave when we found out where you're going to
Ramadi instead of where we were originally supposed to go,
which was in Iraq,
but we knew,
I mean,
I knew Ramadi was going to be the,
uh,
the best place to deploy to and
we show up over there.
And what was cool,
I thought about with,
uh,
with that deployment is the way we task organized and every basically every
leader got their own element.
Yeah,
yeah.
And put you guys,
it was like,
oh yeah,
you know how you've been working for this and we've been all with,
no,
you're going out on your own.
You're,
you're in charge.
And that was a,
that was awesome.
And that what made me feel good was that when we were in the workup and we made
you guys run operations,
even though you were new guys and made you put you in pressure situations and
put you in charge of ground force commander while you were,
you know,
most troops didn't do that.
But I knew that there was a possibility.
And furthermore,
what happens if you know you're a platoon commander gets killed,
what happens if I get killed?
And then you're the guy,
then you got to be able to step up and run stuff.
And so we did that through the chain of command and,
and we did,
I will admit to this,
we made sure that we hit crushed the workup and then it was like,
okay we've dominated,
okay now we start training the new guys up on how to lead.
And that was,
that was important too because it's you want to do well in the workup you want
you,
cause that's where your reputation has a task and your comes from is how well
you do going through these various training box.
That's why we earned earned the spot.
To be able to go to Iraq.
Right.
Because the thing is is that some guys are going elsewhere and you're all via
look,
I mean you're all vying cause you want to go to combat and some guys are going
someplace else,
not in Iraq.
And um,
you know,
I hate to say it,
but that's not where any of us really wanted to go.
Nothing to say about that.
If you are in the seal teams,
you want to go to war.
That's right.
We all wanted to go to war.
That's what we were fighting for.
We were competing.
There's three tasks,
units.
We were competing as a task unit to get top spot to the most dangerous place.
And that's what we want to go.
And that turned out to be Ramadi.
Now,
by the way,
not on that workout too,
just from a leadership perspective.
And if you remember,
you know,
not everybody made it through the workup.
Um,
they were guys who were cut loose,
um,
safety issues,
not stepping up,
not leading,
right.
Pushing that leadership opportunity to down to the junior officer or whatever
and not stepping up or doing something unsafe or just not having what it took.
And um,
you know,
and you know,
just from a leadership perspective,
you have to be willing to make that hard decision and reality.
And I know,
you know,
you and life have talked about it when you've given everybody that guy every
opportunity,
when you've evaluated it and you've kept notes and you've tried to train and
you've tried to correct,
it's not a hard decision.
Right.
Actually,
the commodore,
I don't know if you were there,
but the commodore asked me,
we were on deployment and he goes,
you know,
hey,
hey
Jocko,
this is in front of everyone.
He says,
you know,
well,
I shouldn't say everyone was from in front of the leadership.
He says,
hey,
how were the guys that were in workup maybe weren't performing up to par?
How are they doing over here?
And I was like,
sir,
they're not in this task and not here.
That's right.
Yeah.
They didn't make it.
Yes.
Right.
They've been removed.
That's right.
So,
yeah,
that's a great point.
And again,
it's hard thing to do cause you,
cause you're really,
you're really wrecking someone's life.
Well,
think about it,
right?
So this is a guy who was who,
so there's a guy who's an officer,
right?
So you're,
I mean,
we didn't really,
we kind of glaze through it,
but it's hard to get a spot to go to buds as an officer.
It's very competitive.
So this is a guy who was an officer who got a spot to go to buds,
made it through buds,
which is hard.
Um,
made it through.
Sqt got to a platoon.
This,
this guy is not a slouch physically,
you know what I mean?
Like this is not,
this is not some loser.
You know,
this is a guy who knows a great American,
right?
Patriotic Person.
That's right.
Great Guy who stepped up,
who made it through something that many,
many other men could not make it through and had to make a hard decision.
Um,
you know,
on your part with the Delta platoon commander to not have this guy continue with
us.
And so if that can happen,
even within the seal teams,
any of he goes,
we were listening.
Right.
I mean,
don't you think that's also possible that within your organization you might
have to make a similar kind of decision?
We also have to make that decision in the seal teams.
Yup.
We're not exempt from making that decision.
Yeah.
And also very much like the civilian sector.
Um,
you know,
there's HR basically in the military there's HR,
there's,
there's human resource department and you can't just walk into,
and I'm like,
this guy a firearm.
That's right.
No.
Okay.
Well what have you counseled them?
Has you paperwork on him?
Does he know that Dave,
you verbally have you written it.
It's all these things.
That's where we went through that whole procedure.
And you know,
if there's an extreme case,
of course you can,
you can make it happen,
but it's going to cost you a little bit of political capital.
Because honestly,
if I'm your boss and you come to me and say,
Hey,
I want to fire this guy.
And I say,
okay,
why?
Well,
I don't,
you know,
he's not doing his job anymore.
And I said,
okay,
did you counsel them?
No,
not yet.
But I want to fire him anyways.
That's going to cost you some political capital.
Yeah.
I'm actually looking at you going,
wait a second,
why didn't you train this guy?
Yeah.
You as a leader,
why didn't she step up and train this guy?
What are you doing?
Cause it,
cause that can be a cop out,
right?
Hey,
if I'm too lazy to train,
Mentor,
then you're copping out as leader.
But if you've done all those things as a leader and you can really document that
and see that and the guy's still not performing,
then the next leadership decision is tough part way.
And that really is,
I mean that really is one of the best things about the seal teams is,
is when you're raising your guys up,
when you,
when you're teaching guys,
which you know,
and you're saying,
hey man,
this is what you need to do.
Hey Bro,
here's what,
here's the way this works.
Here's what you did over here.
Here's what you should do.
You know,
that's just,
that's your,
that's your legacy.
That's what you're leaving behind is,
is,
hey,
this is what I learned and I want to teach it to as many guys as I can.
That's what you're trying to do.
So if your lab,
if you're not doing that,
that's jacked up,
you know,
that's jacked up and it's the same thing.
The civilian
sector,
you don't,
here's a good one.
Uh,
I was working and we work with companies and I was working with a company the
other day and they got a guy who sort of,
you know,
oh,
well,
well maybe he's not the best mentor,
right?
But he wants to get promoted,
of course,
cause everyone wants to get promoted.
So this guy wants to get promoted and they're trying to,
they haven't had luck saying,
look,
you got to be a mentor.
You've got to lead.
You've got to be a better leader.
You've got to raise people up.
And,
uh,
I just,
you know,
talk,
talk to the boss.
And I said,
well,
ask him this question.
Yeah.
You know what?
I definitely am looking forward to promoting you.
Gimme the three names of people that you've prepared to take your position,
right?
Goose eggs,
That's going to be goose eggs cause he hasn't done that.
That's right.
So that's a key component.
You know,
you definitely want to,
you want to be as a leader,
you should be looking for your replacement all the time.
And I with with,
with life and the,
with the Delta between commander,
I wanted those guys be able to do my job and that's my whole goal.
And I wanted you to be able to do my job right.
And,
and I'll tell you by the time we went on deployment,
they,
everyone pretty much could do my job.
So that,
that was success for me because guess what that allowed me to do on deployment.
But look at the look up and look out and figured out what we're going to do next
and all that other stuff.
So that should be your goal from a leadership perspective for sure.
And as you just pointed out,
when you get to a situation where you've done the coaching,
you've done the mentoring,
you've done the counseling,
you've written,
you've set the expectation,
you have a person that's stolen and cutting the mustard,
you got to go.
Not a hard decision at the end.
You have to be loyal.
People get mixed up too.
Cause there's a loyalty component because you formed those relationships.
You just talked to her about an hour about this big relationship with all these
people.
Well guess what?
You have a relationship with that person that you're about to fire too.
But then the question becomes are you going to be loyal to that individual?
You can be loyal to the teams because you're hurting the tough side.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
It's the team.
Yup.
So that's that.
We went on deployment with a strong bunch of pipe hitters.
All right,
so we get on deployment.
We you,
you guys,
we kind of,
and this is again,
this is something Tony and I talked about.
We were task organizing.
We changed that.
We changed it on a fairly regular basis.
Okay.
We know what this area is getting hot,
we need more guys over there and we would just kind of,
there's a lot to do.
There's a lot to do and then a lot of work to be done.
It was a lot,
a lot of bad guys.
Um,
when you,
when you look back and you're kind of,
so now you're on your first combat deployment,
what was the thing that struck you as day?
Like,
okay,
this is what,
cause I'll tell you,
people ask me that.
Like the first fire fight I got in while my first deployment to Iraq.
And honestly I was like,
okay.
I felt like I was 100% prepared.
I agree completely.
And I was like,
okay,
cool.
Hey guys.
You know,
he's just very simple,
very straightforward.
So some guys said to me one time,
and this is an outside guy and said,
he goes,
because it seems to me that in the seal teams he goes to stress inoculation
really well.
And so I would say yes because that is exactly my same first firefight I got in.
I was like,
no big
deal.
And you know,
look,
you know,
when the rounds are close,
right?
Like you know what that sounds like and they're,
and they're really close and it's no big deal by the way.
It's not really very loud when they're shooting at you.
Right?
I mean you hear a certain sound.
Um,
but then of course he's fire maneuver and it gets a little loud.
But that's awesome.
It's just like every drill we've ever done and it was no big deal.
It was just,
it was almost habit at that point.
You can do exactly the newer,
so no big deal.
The first,
the first time I went out in a Humvee in Ramadi.
So keep in mind,
like you said in the introduction,
we got there guys,
we're getting IED and killed every single day.
Every day the message traffic came over and it was Kia,
you know,
IED.
So first Humvee ride,
I go out in and I'm looking out the window.
And by the way,
like you can't really roll these windows down.
It's not like you can,
you don't want to roll these windows down by their way.
Proof windows.
You want to keep them up right.
And you know,
so like you actually can't shoot back if you want to write the only guy that can
shoot back as your turret gunner.
And for the first like I would just say minute and a half,
I was like wincing.
I was like waiting for this clack to go,
you know?
And then finally I was like,
you know what,
there's nothing I can do about it.
And I literally let it go right then.
So that was that.
That was like,
that's a strong memory.
Like I remember even for all the training,
and again,
the first fire fight was no big deal.
And um,
but driving down in a Humvee,
sitting in the back,
completely helpless.
I mean,
you have two choices in life is a lot like this.
You can sit there and worry yourself away about it.
Well,
is it this intersection is at this intersection or just go,
you know what,
here's the deal.
I can't control it,
so I'm just going to be ready.
So when it's my time to bust out this door or do whatever we got to do to do an
immediate action drill or whatever,
I'm ready to do it.
And the rest of it,
you just let go.
You let go.
Because anything else is not effective.
Yeah.
You,
you're not,
you're not.
Yeah.
It's not only just are you worried,
but now you're,
you're actually doing things bad.
You're actually being negative here.
You're thinking about things that you shouldn't be thinking about and is not
helping you.
It's not helping your team.
So I like that.
Just to,
just to kind of sum up what you said,
you were in Ramadi for six months,
you were scared for about a minute and 30 seconds.
Yeah.
And after that you're like,
all right.
And I think that's,
that's the attitude that
I think that's the best I hate.
I don't know if this is the right thing to say or not,
but to accept the fact that there's things you can control that you can not
control.
And that one of those things is,
you know,
an ID,
a sniper bullet.
I mean there's things that you can do to influence.
Cause guess what?
We do training.
We prepare,
we're keeping our eyes peeled.
We're taking routes that we know have been cleared to the best of our ability.
We're,
we're,
we're on the street,
we're moving,
we're moving from cover to cover.
We're doing everything that we can.
But guess what?
It doesn't matter.
You can do everything right and doesn't matter.
You can still get blown up.
You can still get shot.
That's the way it is.
So if you sit around and just about that all the time,
it's just going to drive you crazy one.
And number two,
it's going to make you do your job worse.
Yeah.
Cause you're gonna be less aggressive.
And I think
you gotta stay aggressive to stay alive.
You,
you want to be aggressive.
You want to be,
you know what?
Yeah,
we'll go make that happen.
Oh there,
do I want to sit in the vehicle in order to get out and get out and get some
ground?
I mean,
that's just the type of thing,
that mindset,
it's a mindset that wins.
Yep.
That's it.
It's the winning mindset.
And if your goal is to win,
did you have to recognize a certain thought processes are not effective and they
take away from your ability to win and will ask if people get worried about
stuff,
that kind of thing.
Right.
So,
um,
you just,
you take a step back.
You,
I want to win,
right?
The Guy said to me one time,
hey Ya,
do you think,
do you think fear is a,
is a useful emotion?
I thought about it for a second cause I never heard lots of different people
talk about fear and you know,
this is an ad.
And you know,
I would say for,
maybe I'll change this one day,
but right now this is where I've come to one fear,
um,
maybe for the caveman who's walking through the jungle and they get attacked by
the saber tooth tiger.
And that fear,
that fight or flight response is enough to make him react in a moment in order
to avoid being slashed by the tiger.
But other than that,
fear was not effective in battle because you do not make good decisions when
acting in fear.
And you have a better chance of survival.
You make better decisions and you have a better chance of winning in defeating,
in crushing the enemy when you remain calm.
When you do Ooda loop,
observe,
Orient,
decide,
act.
Yeah.
I've got,
I could ask to,
I've obviously,
you get asked about fear a lot and you know,
I always say,
look,
fear is the fear is not a bad thing because it's the thing that makes you go,
okay,
I need to be ready.
Right.
Is the thing that makes you rehearse.
It's a thing that makes you say,
okay,
cause you,
and for me,
okay,
the,
again,
the fear wasn't about the fear of getting killed,
getting blown up.
The fear was always about,
I want to,
I don't want to do a bad job.
I don't want to make a bad decision that I'll tell you,
you're in a leadership position.
That is the heaviest fear that you have is I make a mistake,
my team does something that doesn't,
doesn't,
okay,
bring credit upon us as a unit.
And by that I mean it doesn't do a good job.
Like you're just,
I don't even know where that comes from.
It's just want to do a good job.
And the fear is,
hey,
I hope I don't do anything that gets my guys hurt or killed.
I hope don't do anything that's a bad decision that makes,
that does.
That hurts a strategically as a nation.
Yup.
Those are the two fears that I think make you a hearse,
make you practice,
make you reinforce,
make you
okay
aware of what's happening,
but you can't.
What you can't do,
I mean,
for me,
if your fear is making me aggressive,
like,
oh,
I think this guy's got to go to do something to me.
Cool.
I'm afraid of him Coleman to attack them.
I'm going to kill him.
You know,
I'm going to take him out.
I'm going to do something.
You know?
And I actually see that time.
I see that in MMA to where when you see someone that happened to somebody where
they get a little bit,
they get a little bit or something.
If they,
if they let that fear make them back off and go into a defensive mode.
It's exactly what you just said.
If it makes you into a defensive mode,
it's good.
You're gonna the person is going to cause,
man,
you can smell that.
That's right.
You can smell that.
So when I think the reaction to fear,
it's like,
oh,
I'm afraid right now Coleman to attack.
I have to attack like,
oh,
I don't feel comfortable about where the troop is moving right now or where my
squad is moving right now.
I don't think it's a good thing.
Cool.
I'm going to attack them and take some high ground.
I'm gonna Maneuver.
That's why it's healthy.
It's a healthy fear that that's healthy.
But you're also trained and prepared mentally for that kind of thing.
Most people,
when they start acting in fear,
they start making poor decisions.
So in that sense it's like,
Hey,
get over your fears because you have to recognize that when you're acting in
fear,
you'll have a less desirable outcome.
Then if you can get over it,
calm down,
sip,
you know,
observe,
Orient,
decide,
act.
No doubt about it.
All right.
What about,
what about just plain leadership challenges?
I mean,
here we are stressful deployment.
Yup.
It was,
it was the most stressful deployment that anybody had had up until that point in
Iraq.
Yup.
Um,
and even talking to,
you know,
the Vietnam guys,
this was a stressful deployment,
a very stressful deployment in the amount of combat that was happening.
Oh,
urban combat hap,
things happen so fast.
Yep.
Uh,
so,
but,
but from a leadership perspective,
what did you,
was there anything that you didn't expect?
Was there any lesson that got confirmed?
Termed?
Yeah,
so,
and it's funny because,
you know,
over time in the deployment you really mature,
um,
even in a short amount of time.
And I,
and I'll give you a quick,
quick story.
So it was,
it was one of my last ops before I left country and there was another unit that
had come in to kind of partner up with us.
And,
uh,
we went into this op.
And so the officer in that unit,
who's a good friend of mine,
by the way,
um,W was,
it might have been his second combat op.
Right.
And so I've been on,
I don't even know how many at that point.
And uh,
so we went and did this operation and it involves some army units and a,
so we're sitting in this position and,
um,
so
like classic blunder,
the Army Guy who sitting there is on the rooftop and he's smoking a cigarette.
Like,
like the classic World War Two sniper victim smoking a cigarette.
Yeah.
Trail of smoke going up.
And uh,
I mean this is a classic,
I mean,
single sniper shot shoots him and it,
it just,
I mean,
it misses his face.
Well,
let me put it this way,
it took his ear a little off,
right.
Round cracks under the wall behind us.
That's it.
Immediately everybody just by black,
like just unloads firefight.
Right.
And,
uh,
so we're calling the metadata for this guy because it Kinda,
it's still cut them pretty good.
And,
um,
I'm trying to figure out,
there's gonna be any more fire or whatever the situation is.
So,
so this guy is like,
well on my case,
so time to call the QRF and get out of here.
He's like,
well,
you know,
I think I'm like,
you think what dude,
what else do you think is possibly going to come from this?
And you know,
I mean I probably would've thought,
hey,
maybe we can still get something from this.
It was when my first or second.
Right.
But it was just clear like,
I mean,
at this point,
I mean we've already,
we've already got a lot of guys hurt on this deployment.
We've already lost mark and um,
a few other guys.
So,
you know,
because it's already been shot at this point.
So,
um,
yeah,
you have to weigh like what,
what more are you going to gain?
I mean,
first of all,
this guy,
just this sniper just got a bead on this guy.
I mean in,
by the grace of God,
he is still alive and we've shot like,
so what else is going to happen?
I mean they're either just going to set up and get a better position or get
another shot,
but they certainly aren't going to do anything.
We certainly aren't going to see anything that they don't want us to see at this
point.
So the battlefield is lost.
I mean,
this op is a,
it's over.
It's it's time to pull chalks and go.
So anyway,
that army came and busted down the swan with the fighting.
It was awesome.
I mean,
I love the breading Bradley fighting vehicle.
Um,
but you know,
that's just sort of like a quick,
it's like obvious.
It's obvious to me at that point and I on a Monday morning comp,
you know,
quarterback 10 years later as I'm explaining this,
like anybody's listening can go,
well yeah,
obviously time to go,
right?
But you know what,
you're in that position and guys are still trying to get after it and there's
still things going on out there.
You might think,
well,
maybe there's still something
you can do here.
Yeah.
And by the way that there was other times where similar situations happen in
different decisions were made and they worked out great.
Yep.
You know,
and so I think your overall statement is like you gained perspective right over
time and you should be able to look at things from a,
from a better perspective and from a higher altitude for a lack of a better way
to say it.
You are able to understand what's happening on the battlefield more.
Yeah,
that's definitely something that if people are listening and it's something that
they want to become aware,
it's,
if it's something that you can actually act on because that perspective,
it can be gained through time and experience.
But it can also be gained by detachment and saying,
okay,
what am I really doing here right now?
What are we really going to gain?
And you can make a faster progress down the line to have to make good judgment
calls based on not just experience but just on knowledge and,
and,
and trying to capture the right perspective at the right time.
Plus a big tactic for that.
For those guys who was slowly evolving.
And,
and happened,
uh,
after we left.
So is there anything else that you start that,
that you learned again that you didn't expect or that was useful for you?
Okay.
Eight.
From a leadership perspective.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
I found myself in a position a lot of times of kind of stitching the,
keeping it platoon to stitch together,
you know,
in an intense situation,
guys start to have different opinions about things,
you know,
they do indeed.
Yup.
And so,
um,
so on this deployment,
I was not the platoon commander,
right.
My good friend was the platoon commander.
And when you're in a position of leadership,
you're making a lot of hard decisions and not everybody always agrees with the
decision that gets made.
And so a lot of times the role I needed to fill was to back my platoon commander
and continue to keep the platoon together behind the platoon commander because
he,
he had,
he was tasked with making some hard decisions.
So,
um,
sometimes it was,
you know,
sometimes,
so look,
I would just do analogy I would give to you is that you may be enrolled in a
company,
in an organization where the best thing you can do to be part of the team is to
help keep the team on focus for the mission.
And that might mean,
you know,
spending some time with one or two guys who are over here,
uh,
having a disagreement about the decision or which way things are going.
Okay.
And truly one of the best ways that you end up having to do that or doing that
is number one,
you build the relationships with the guys,
right?
So they know and trust you.
Number two,
your platoon commander is got a lot of stuff on his plate,
right?
And so one of the easiest things for him to cut short is the guise of,
of explaining,
hey,
here's why this is going on and here's why this is going to,
so you as the intermediary isn't okay,
I know what he's doing.
I know why he's making this decision.
Let me explain this down.
The chain of command.
That's right.
And that's so helpful.
So helpful.
And when you've got guys in the platoon or any organization,
a high performing organization that are really strong willed and have strong
opinions and by the way are an intelligent and it can make really articulate
points as to why they don't agree with something.
You know,
again,
my role in that,
in that situation was to ensure that mission success continued to happen,
that we were still effective as a unit.
And that meant me kind of behind the scenes trying to keep,
keep some guys on board.
Yeah,
and it's interesting,
I'm sure people have noted this already,
but when you said there's these different people inside of what platoon,
I mean just if you listen to the podcast that I just,
where did with retired senior chief Tonia fratty and you,
you guys personalities are,
are very,
very different.
Very,
And that's just some of what you get in a soup tune and you know what,
it's not just some would get seal up tune.
It's some of what you get any,
any organization.
That's right.
There's no clones.
There's not people being turned out,
they can have the same background,
they can go to the same school,
they can have the same level of experience,
they can be totally different people.
That's the way it is and that's the way it is in the seal teams and that's the
way it is.
And every organization is part of why we're so good.
Right?
Cause you've got guys that think differently and then you have problems
differently.
Yes.
But I like the fact of what you're saying is you had to be,
you found yourself in the role of okay you know what?
I got to make sure that the guys understand where the platoon commanders coming
from with the God that if there's something that actually makes sense,
I got to bring it back over to the commander and say look,
this isn't one of the guys you know complaining about something.
Here's the legitimate point that's being made.
Right?
And then you guys can have that discussion discussion.
Maybe brings in one of those guys that were good with,
tell me what you're talking about here.
And then you guys can move forward and come up with the best possible plan.
But yeah,
as a peacemaker for all practical purposes is,
is what's his,
where you,
what you end up being.
And um,
you know,
before I w w the one of them
is needed because it wasn't a lot of peace over there.
Not a lot of peace.
One of the stories,
I think that little Mikey story here that kind of shows you the level of
violence that was happening
yeah.
In Ramadi.
So I came to visit.
Okay.
Uh,
yeah cause I was a,
I was on the other side of Ramadi and,
and the guys from Delta first,
a small section of guys from Delta and then all of them ended up on the,
on the eastern side of Ramadi with the first of the five or six band of
brothers.
Okay.
Awesome.
Outstanding unit.
All amazing guys to a man and with an amazing commander.
But so Delta platoon ended up over there.
Well anyways,
I had gone over to visit,
go,
go do some ops with them and see what was going on.
And when I showed up,
you know,
I showed up and this was a few is probably like a month and a half in,
uh,
because the guys had taken over some crappy uh,
okay.
Building and full metal jacket,
full metal jacket and had built it out.
FMJ So if you guys seen the movie full metal jacket,
that's a scene in the movie where these guys,
these buildings are all blown out.
Well this building were not,
not just the seals,
but a bunch of guys,
army guys lived in this building and it was all blown out and it looked like
this is awesome.
It was awesome metal jacket.
And when we first got in there,
the first one we first went out there,
it was dirt.
It was literally dirt floors,
just mosquitoes everywhere.
It was told it was just horrible.
And now some time has passed.
And the guys,
of course you put seal somewhere,
they're going to dial some stuff in the CBS that we have with this.
Awesome.
Oh my gosh.
The cvs we had were phenomenal and we don't know what cvs are there.
They're sort of the navy's version of engineers and they're,
they're fanatically hard workers.
And the crew that we had with us in Ramadi,
that was we,
they were part of our task unit.
They were just total hard chargers and bust their ass and make stuff happen.
So they had,
and the other thing,
the other thing you have to do when you're a CB is you have to learn to acquire
things because there's a lack of things in combat zones.
Right.
And so you're good.
CBE can come up with,
let's call it,
you know,
120 sheets of four by eight plywood,
right.
That our master,
our CVE master chief.
Awesome.
We got there.
Did they had,
they had these racks
built out for us in,
this was blown out concrete building that had like shelves and stairs to go to.
The upper duty was awesome.
Yeah,
it was.
So they take date,
that's what they had done is taken,
it just built the like into these basically small plywood condominium,
full metal jacket.
And I saw,
I showed up there one time and you know,
we're hanging out and you know,
the platoon commanders give me a little debrief on stuff and just kind of
telling me how things are going.
And then someone says,
Hey,
did you see Mikey's video?
And I go,
I go,
no.
And they go,
go,
go see Mikey's video.
And so I go,
okay,
so they go,
he's rooms back there.
And what is his room say on it?
Oh man,
Mikey's palace or something.
Like I would a great story about Mike.
He's palace by the way.
So go ahead.
Let's talk about Mikey's palace.
So the,
so the cvs had built the,
these awesome plywood paradise for us.
And um,
so,
you know,
people would sleep,
we would sleep at all different times,
right?
I mean daytime,
nighttime,
whatever.
Because the obstacle was so intense and so everyone was totally blacked out.
And I got like an odd sleeping style.
Like I could,
well,
as a mall rat,
we know we have slightly different cycle.
So Mikey had a different cycle.
Like everybody would be asleep and I would be awakened back.
Ah,
I always could find Mikey awake.
And Mike,
so you go in,
you go in,
he was on the ground floor and so you'd go down and it was pitch black and you
gotta like feel your way through it,
all these bunks and then you'd go down around this corner,
down this hallway and you make a sharp right.
And um,
and then there'd be this faint glow coming from Mike Keith Palace.
And so Mike,
he's bunk was the last one up against the wall and there was like an extra like
three feet between his bunk in the wall this way,
like the way it worked out.
And so he had like these tapestries that his family had sent him hanging from
the wall and,
and you'd have like Poncho liners all hung out blocking the whole thing out.
And so it was all dark.
He was like his little cave and you go back in there and uh,
I don't know where he got and he had like extra pillows on his bunk and like he
had his laptop,
like,
like rigged.
That's like a TV screen.
Have you always be watching movies?
And he always had all kinds of Guidant back there.
So I go back in there and I go in a glow from Mikey's palace.
I go back in there and then we just sit there and go,
hey man,
you want some of that?
You'd have beef Jerky,
that's sodas.
He'd have like Ramen,
ramen noodles.
And he'd always had,
he had like this heating element there.
Like once like you plug into the wall,
he's like,
hey man,
and you a cook up the heating element,
boiling water,
right.
There are some Brahmin if ever I was hungry in the middle of the night,
I could get down there to Mikey's pass.
I knew I could get some grub and he United hang out and watch movies and stuff.
And uh,
he was always up weird hours.
Like,
man,
it was just cool man.
He had just,
yeah,
it was cool.
Pictures,
posters hanging on the wall.
He had that thing correct out.
Failed.
Yeah.
So these guys are like,
Hey,
have you seen Mike?
He's movie.
And I go,
no.
It's like,
oh,
we'll go back to Mikey's palace and check it out.
And so I make my way back there.
Same thing,
you know,
you're making your way back there.
The dark at the headlamp on,
even though it's noon or something like that outside,
but the place is blacked out.
Anyways,
I get back
there and I'm like Mikey and,
and he,
he didn't know I was at that.
I was at Corregidor,
you know,
so he was just,
hey,
you know,
kind of like hop two or whatever in a very,
I don't want to make that sound too extreme.
Right.
You know?
But he was surprised to see the commander.
Right.
But,
um,
anyways,
I'm like Mikey,
he's like,
oh.
He's like,
Hey,
you know,
when these all chill.
And I said,
Hey,
let me see your movie man.
And he goes,
he gets a smile on his face and I go,
okay,
this must be addressed.
So anyways,
he breaks out,
his camera is showing me the movie on the camera.
Right.
But it's got volume and I'm sitting there watching it.
And any ways that the movie is,
it's a,
a big firefight going on.
It's just,
there's,
this is a big bad firefight.
There's machine gun fire going off and he's literally sticking his hand up with
the camera above the edge of a rooftop and he's filming,
you can see stuff getting shot and whatever.
And then the funny part is he brings the camera down.
He's,
you know,
hiding in this rooftop and he points the camera at himself.
And the area of Ramadi that they were working in was a place called the melodic
district.
And like many things in the military,
you had taken on its own little life,
its own little legend,
the melodic district.
And Mikey points the camera at himself and he says,
it's the Moodle out the mood I baby.
And uh,
so it was really funny.
Yeah.
And any,
I get done watching this and of course I'm still,
you know,
mister big bad Jocko and,
and I get to Washington,
I go,
hey Mikey,
listen bro,
when you're out there,
you shouldn't be filming stuff you need to be on are gone.
I mean,
that's just,
that's just what you need to be doing.
Do you need to get on your gun and,
and you need to keep shooting.
You need to be putting down suppressive fire.
And He,
and he looks at me and he's kind of sheepishly,
you know,
cause he felt bad and he goes,
he goes,
he goes like,
Hey sir,
I was out of Ammo
and I started laughing because that's probably an 800 rounds,
maybe,
maybe more,
probably more.
Probably probably 1200.
Yeah.
Just a massive amount of machine gun rounds that he'd gone through and he'd shot
them all.
That's what Winchester means.
Means you'd shot,
you had nothing left.
And he said,
you know,
sir,
I'm sorry sir.
I was,
I was Winchester and I just started laughing.
I was like,
well,
if you're Winchester makes them good movers.
I guess my brother he got after.
Yeah.
So that's uh,
another good Mikey story.
So,
okay.
You actually ended up going home early from deployment.
Yup.
And because you had another kid on the way.
Gunner.
He,
um,
and the thing is,
is it's like God,
I mean,
hindsight's 2020 men,
you know,
when,
when man,
when this stuff goes like this,
um,
Ma,
we had point,
we knew that that was going to be the end of the deployment.
And so it's like,
all right,
cool.
You know,
you just go back with the,
with the ad bond for the redeploy.
And so that was all part of the plan from
day one basically.
All right,
cool.
Um,
because my first son had been born on my last appointment,
so as it was,
and,
and by the way,
so it started heading back,
wife gives birth early anyway,
so there you go.
Two deployments to kids,
not their common story for a lot of military guys.
Um,
but for people who are not yet,
I mean,
imagine like you're not being there for your,
for either of your kids.
My wife,
she's a trooper,
but she was running out of steam.
Um,
so it was cool to be able to go back,
at least try to be there,
but gunners always been in a hurry,
so he came early.
Um,
and then so yeah,
went back,
um,
start handling the redeploy.
And by that he means we're some guy comes home from deployment a little bit
early to start basically preparing for us to come home,
getting ready for all the administrative stuff that's going to take place.
And Andrew was that guy and there's like that happen.
And then there was like three other guys that like a week later came.
They all love me too.
So it was,
it was,
you know,
near the end,
but it tough but a tough call anyway.
And then,
um,
I mean,
I remember where I was when,
when I got the word,
so,
you know,
I was back at the team and,
uh,
I was,
I was actually chatting with Delta platoon commander,
um,
via a method that we use.
And He,
uh,
I just,
I knew they were going out and,
um,
and I mean,
I distinctly remember going all right,
may get some,
get some for me,
you know,
and,
uh,
so I was home,
I got the call at like 1230 at night,
um,
our time,
local.
And,
uh,
so I knew right away that was one of our guys.
Uh,
they wouldn't,
you know,
nothing over the,
over the phone specifically,
but I knew because I had just talked to our guys,
you know,
and I was like,
God,
I'm money.
So I raced into,
so you get to call,
it just says,
come to work,
get to work.
And I'm like,
all right,
so,
and admittedly I'm a little frantic,
you know,
because these are my brothers,
and I'm not there and it's really hard.
So,
you know,
you can have some survivor's guilt over that kind of thing,
you know?
Um,
uh,
you know,
it seems like,
Hey,
look,
we got this deployments basically over.
Um,
and go back thinking you're making a right decision,
trying to balance stuff with your family.
Um,
and then for that to happen.
Uh,
and you know,
he's one of my guys,
he's one of my guys and I wasn't there.
And,
uh,
that's hard.
Um,
you know,
it's been almost 10 years now and time helps to heal those kinds of things,
but I had a lot of guilt over that.
And,
um,
so anyway,
we kind of figure out what's going on.
Um,
I get the brief and figure out who it is.
So,
um,
start figuring out,
okay,
so now it's,
now it's a race for those guys.
I don't know.
I mean,
look,
here's the thing.
We live in a 24,
seven news world,
um,
and it's a race to notify the before they find out through some other means.
And,
uh,
he lives up in Orange County.
So we started assembling the team,
um,
and you know,
admirals and,
uh,
commodores are involved and,
it looked,
this is the second guy that we have not lost seals in Iraq to this point,
mark and Mike now.
So,
um,
uh,
you know,
who's going to go up and do the notification?
And I mean,
like I had to like dig my heels in and I was like,
listen,
this is my guy.
I'm going.
And it was at first like,
hmm.
And then I was like,
no,
no.
I'm going and thank God I did that because I mean,
I wouldn't have it any other way.
Um,
we're racing,
we put,
put the guys together,
throw the blue zone,
we drive it up.
And,
um,
you know,
look,
when we,
when we got to Mikey's family's house,
um,
you know,
look at all they wanted was to talk to somebody who knew Mikey and the other
four guys that were standing there didn't know him,
didn't serve with them,
didn't work up with him,
didn't deploy with them.
And you know,
in this grand scheme of God's plan,
I have to ask,
you know,
we pulled over before pulling up,
pulling up to the house and put on our blues.
And I literally thought to myself,
okay,
that we are about to give the worst possible news to,
to a parent that their kid is dead.
And,
um,
I remember thinking,
you know,
God just used me right now.
I don't know why I'm here in this timing.
Um,
but just work,
work through me,
just use me,
you know.
Uh,
so,
you know,
we knocked on their door and,
and,
um,
you know,
Mrs Monsu or looked out and she later new,
that we,
I mean,
she took a few minutes to get to the door.
She looked out and saw five men standing there and blues.
Um,
so that was very hard.
You know,
you go in and obviously family is upset and you're doing the best you can to
keep it together.
I mean,
for me,
this was my guide.
This was my brother and I'm standing there giving them the news and trying to
keep it together myself.
And,
um,
you know,
the,
the good news is,
is that one by one they sort of looked around and said,
well,
did anybody know Mikey?
And I was like,
yeah,
I knew Mike.
He is mine.
And,
uh,
so they politely asked everybody to leave.
Um,
but wanted me to stay and just talk about the deployment,
tell stories about Mikey,
what he was like,
what was going on in,
you know,
I want to,
uh,
okay.
The monsters are an unbelievable family and I totally want to respect their
privacy.
Absolutely.
The family.
Um,
and they're just,
they just been so amazingly humble and gracious through this whole thing.
And I just don't want to sit here and tell stories about,
about this.
Right.
I don't want to do it.
Um,
one of the things that are the,
the,
the only,
the only thing I'll,
I'll say about this again,
out of disrespect for the monster,
we're family,
um,
is w when you just said about about,
mmm.
You tell them what deployment was like.
Well,
in talking to them,
one of the things that they said was their impression of the deployment.
So,
so like I said,
and you guys have heard stories about Ramadi and you could go and you can go on
youtube and just put Ramadi 2006 and you'll see what Ramadi was like.
That's what Ramadi was like.
And it was incredibly violent and crazy.
And these guys,
Charlie and Delta tune,
we're in the thick of it,
in the thick of it on a almost daily basis.
And the reason I'm building that up is because the emails that might get sent
home to his family were,
oh yeah,
I haven't fun.
Not much going on here.
Right.
Don't worry about me.
We're just training some Iraqis.
I'll,
we're just,
uh,
trying to work on the infrastructure.
Don't worry about me.
It's all good here.
I'll be home in a little bit though.
Those are the kinds of emails that he was sending home in order to make sure
that his family wasn't worried about it.
Right.
And it shows you what kind of a guy that Mikey was.
MMM.
So,
so
any,
is there anything else,
again,
without,
without going into your personal yeah.
You know,
your personal interactions with this incredible family that you want to say.
And maybe from the perspective of,
as much as,
I hate to say this,
there's many other people that are going to do this job being this person that
does the notification.
Is there anything else that you could give advice to people that have to do this
job or you know,
if they,
if that ever befalls people that are here.
We get a lot,
Andrew.
We get a lot of big,
a lot of military guys that,
that reach out to me all the time that are active duty,
that are doing the work and anything that strikes you as something that you
learned from this experience.
Here's what I learned is the worst thing I've ever done in my life.
And the worst thing and combat itself was a piece of cake compared to this.
I would love to go back to combat any issues or concerns or anything from my
military service was completely centered around.
This is an extremely heavy burden to bear.
So if you were ever in this position,
I don't have any good advice for you.
There's nothing you can do to prepare yourself for that,
this type of situation.
The only thing I could tell you is reach out to guys who've done it before.
I will gladly talk you through it because one of the best solves that I've found
for this kind of pain is hanging out with your brothers and spending time with
them.
Um,
I will always have time for someone who's had that be a Keiko.
Always call me.
Let's go out.
Let's hang out.
I won't suggest drinking a beer,
but if a beer is what you want to do,
we'll do it.
But the bottom line is,
is that just the intimacy of being around another guy who's been there is very
comforting.
And so,
you know,
when you go through a stressful situation like this,
do not isolate yourself.
There are other guys who have been through this and um,
in a true brother will be,
we'll be willing to take the time for you.
I'll find a time for you no matter what,
no matter how busy I am.
And so,
um,
I just want to be a resource.
Now I know that there's only so many hours in the day,
but if you're going through something,
if you've gone through something like this,
reach out to your brothers,
find a connection to another military guy cause nobody can understand it like
another military guy.
And that's part of the stress of it.
Part of the stress of it is,
is that you don't feel like you can't possibly explain what you're dealing with
to anybody else.
There's no way they could possibly understand and comprehend it.
But another guy has been to combat cancer and we can sit in the room next to
each other.
Even if we sat there and said nothing,
we would get each other.
And so you got to reach out to each other.
Do not isolate.
That's,
that's great advice.
And actually one thing that's very interesting to me is that a,
I get emails from guys and they're basically doing that.
They're going to do that right now with us.
There's some of those guys out there that are better are going okay.
Yeah.
And,
and the message is,
yeah,
I mean,
the military guys who had been through this kind of stuff before,
again,
I was never Keiko.
I'd never even came home from my guys.
You know,
that was another kind of
another kind of misery I guess to does.
No,
you're just sending people home.
It's awful.
Um,
but yeah,
don't isolate yourself.
Talk to your brothers,
find him and tell him what you're thinking about.
Yeah.
And this is awesome,
right?
Because Twitter and Facebook and messages like this,
you know,
we can kind of reconnect.
You know,
we can kind of talk about doing some cool stuff together,
whether it's Jujitsu or running a badass race or doing something to challenge
you physically or mentally.
We all can kind of give ourselves a electronic high five,
you know,
for something bad ass you're still doing today.
And you know what?
Here's the other thing to transition,
man,
man.
So,
so,
so we,
so that happens.
I'm home.
And in February,
2007 I got off active duty and I
so,
so for those of you that don't track in the calendar here,
Mikey died September 29th,
2006 that whole thing on fault.
We got home,
I got home,
I was the last with the last group to leave and we left a Ramadi October 21st it
took us a couple of days to get home,
but we're home.
We get
post deployment leave,
we reassemble,
I do post deployment,
kind of debrief types up.
Then we get post deployment leave.
So now you're talking,
it's December.
All of a sudden December,
you know,
October is November,
it's now it's descent.
Your thanksgiving now it's on this December boom.
And so not much time has gone by.
It's been packed in February.
You're getting,
now that I'm gone and that war machine keeps cranking by the way.
So the guys are back to write and do another platoon.
They're doing predeployment working,
whatever,
dude,
whatever.
It just,
it keeps on cranking.
And then Poof,
I'm out of the navy and I jumped right into the mortgage business because you
know nothing like a natural transition from the seal teams and the battlefield
of Ramadi to do in 30 year fixed mortgages.
And it's,
and it's 2007 though.
So you actually weren't doing fixed mortgages for 30 years that the mortgage
industry,
for those of you that don't know the mortgage industry in 2007 was a place where
a lot of people were making a ton of money and it was about to all come to a
screen.
I was not making a ton of money.
I would just like to add,
I was brand new,
right?
So I leave this steady two week paycheck,
brotherhood and a job I'd wanted to do my entire adult life at that point and
had to just come have a great deployment and get in the morning.
And I did that because I need to be home.
And by the way,
as much as the struggle was to get out and I really,
my heart was truly torn in two opposite directions.
Um,
man,
I look back in the last nine,
10 years that I've had the opportunity to raise in shape my two young boys to be
the young men that they're becoming had been absolutely priceless.
And,
but you know,
so I find myself February sitting in a quiet office of a mortgage office at like
six 30 in the morning cause that's just how I roll.
I got a key,
I'm going to get in there early,
I'm going to figure it out.
And it,
nobody,
no first guys not showing up.
It's like nine,
you know,
I'm in their written guideline books trying to just,
I have no,
I have no paycheck,
have no income.
And so man,
it got rough.
I started to struggle,
I'm struggling financially for one thing,
I'm struggling emotionally,
um,
of struggling and build a new relationships and,
you know,
kind of like a little bit of a chip on the shoulder and a sort of a little bit
of an attitude from combat to trying to build a relationships in the civilian
world.
And it was tough.
Um,
but I mean,
there were mornings I sat there quietly.
And by the way,
that picture that you talked about at the beginning of this deal,
I have that hanging on my wall.
I look at it every single day.
And,
um,
one of the things that continued to drive me and for military guys who are
listening,
um,
as Corny as this may sound,
the legacy of my brothers is what drives me.
Um,
the opportunity to help my fellow veterans drives me,
um,
because I'm,
you know,
doing mortgages.
Yeah.
Not Super Exciting,
right.
But I sat there quietly trying to figure it out.
Um,
I,
I all,
I got divorced,
I lost a house to foreclosure.
I short sold another house.
Um,
there's a time when,
um,
I looked over my young son,
Gunnar is sleeping on the floor.
I got no furniture in the house,
a house that's days from,
it's already been foreclosed and it's days away from the sheriff coming to
essay,
get out.
And that drives me.
And I think about Mickey and the sacrifice that Mikey and mark made.
And it drives me because they made a sacrifice.
And
in some ways this is,
this is bad talk right here.
In some ways I beat myself up that I wasn't on the roof that day with Mikey
because that was my platoon.
And I came home early from my son.
But then I think,
well,
if I had been on that roof,
maybe it could have been me and then there wouldn't be a father there to raise
gunner and to raise Triston into the next generation of warriors.
And either way,
the sacrifice it Mikey made,
he made that so that I could live and I have an obligation to use every ounce of
my ability to use my mind and my body and my drive and my determination to fight
and kick and scratch every single day to honor his legacy,
to build and to mentor young men,
to help my fellow veterans and to make this country a greater country and all of
those things.
The more I do,
the more I feel like I can honor Mikey and his legacy and to do anything else
would be to slight the great sacrifice that he made.
And so take your brothers,
if you're at a military and you're out now you're trying to figure out what we
think your brother's honor them.
Andrew,
you and I were having dinner.
Uh,
actually we were having dinner at the Christening of the USS Michael Montessori
awesome.
The ship.
And you are going into that situation.
You just kind of rattled it off just now.
Like it wasn't no big thing,
right?
Your kid is sleeping on the floor cause you have no bed,
no furniture.
You're that by the way,
that that paycheck you've been accustomed to getting for whatever,
five years in the navy is gone,
right?
When you get out of the military,
after five years,
you don't get anything.
You get nothing.
Right?
So you have no paycheck coming in,
but there's no salary in the mortgage industry,
right?
So it's all a hundred percent commission.
You're son is sleeping on the floor because you have no furniture,
right?
You foreclosed on one house,
you short sold another house,
and you're about to get evicted.
That's your life at this point,
right?
Not to mention in the back of your mind or in the front of your mind,
you got this thought that Mikey died and you weren't there.
Right?
How did you look at all of that
and shrug your shoulders,
Grit your teeth and say,
I'm going to kick this thing's ass.
Where
did you start?
At the very bottom.
I'd like to think I bounced because I hit so hard.
Never give up
the legacy of my teammates.
I mean,
here's the deal.
I think about guys that are committing suicide today or thinking about
committing suicide and
think about this,
do you want to give that nasty enemy even one more victory.
Fuck them.
I am going to win because I am not going to let them defeat me.
And I look at my boys,
I prayed a lot for me.
It's my faith and Jesus Christ saved me.
So I keep fighting.
And you know what,
that's just never gonna quit.
Never.
You are not done until you're six feet under the ain't done.
I would tell you if I ever found myself in combat where I was shot and dying and
often my own and Afghanistan or something like that.
For example,
I would take the glass grenade,
I had pull the pin and laid underneath myself so that when the enemy came to try
and get my gear and they blow themselves up cause I am not done until I am gone.
And even then,
if you've laid the right foundation,
the legacy you leave,
the messages and what you've done to help the next generation,
that's it.
I'm just never gonna quit.
Never.
You can knock me down and I will get back up.
You can not be down and I will get back up.
I will get back up.
I will get back up
obviously.
Well for those of you who don't know cause you don't know Andrew,
he did get back up.
He absolutely got back up.
He now runs a very successful business and is out kicking ass on a daily basis
and taking names and it's been,
you know,
a lot of this,
again w whenever I look at myself and I went on this big little or I went on
this big kind of
tirade about how you need to mentor your people and all that and take care of
your brothers.
Well guess what?
You know where I was when Andrew was going through this shit.
I was working,
he didn't call me.
He didn't and I didn't make myself available.
You know,
so you
go,
you know,
taking care of,
of your friends goes beyond just when they ask for help,
you need to seek them out and make sure that they're doing all right.
Because I let him go.
And that was that.
He got out of the navy and it was bye bye
mine.
I wasn't going to come and ask you,
cause maybe I was a little embarrassed.
You know about how dire my situation was.
So if you're a leader,
just know just like kids who are going through buds,
they're going to hide their injuries.
Right.
Because you know,
I don't want to come to the guy who I respect and say,
Hey,
I am out right now,
bro.
You know,
so I'm just going to keep digging.
And I know we've talked about it.
You're like,
man,
why didn't you come to me?
I don't,
you know what?
It wasn't in my nature to do so.
Yeah,
maybe that wasn't the best decision.
Maybe I should have reached out,
but um,
either way I wasn't gonna quit.
Well,
that's awesome.
It's awesome to see what you've done and see where you're at now.
Like I said,
kicking ass and taking names and,
and raising to a bad ass young men,
they're good boys,
man.
The next generation of warriors,
that's one of the things I've become passionate about.
I'll tell you,
you know,
when you get out and you transition,
it's hard because you leave this brotherhood,
you leave this common,
sent this common goal and you know,
you're fighting for freedom,
you're fighting for liberty and you're fighting for your brother and your
sister,
your right and left.
And then you get into some job where you're sitting at a desk typing on a
computer,
which is boring.
Um,
so you have to look,
here's the deal.
You have to find a purpose behind what you're doing.
And mortgages,
like seriously jumping out of planes,
blowing things up,
shooting guns,
dive in.
Rebreathers on a hall high,
ends up doing 30 year fixed mortgages.
I mean,
Wall Wall.
how do you,
how do you get excited about that?
Look,
you don't,
you don't get excited about doing that.
All right?
I'm gonna be honest with you.
What'd you get excited about it?
It's something else behind it.
And for me,
it's helping my fellow veterans.
So they'll,
you don't know 90% of my business I do VA loans.
Okay?
So why?
Because I want to help my fellow veterans.
Nobody will take care of that are better than I will.
And that's,
that's,
that's my mantra,
right?
If,
if,
if a guy goes down the street,
he will not be taken care of better than if he comes to me because I am deeply
passionate about helping my fellow veterans.
And that's how I get passionate about the job that I do.
Now I found a purpose behind what I'm doing.
And so you might be in some job now that you're out and you might go,
God,
this sucks.
You know,
but find a reason behind.
It could be a small thing,
right?
Like there were jobs in the military that sucked.
They were job.
There's parts of every job that sucks.
You just gotta deal with it.
That's life.
And find a purpose behind what you're doing.
And then,
and then I will just tell you,
this is a,
this is like one of these secrets of life that I have found.
Life is easier when you find a way to help somebody else.
When you find a way to help somebody else,
miraculously,
your problems begin to go away.
So focus on somebody else's problems.
And how you can help them and all of a sudden you forget about yours.
And so find a way to help other veterans.
I see guys,
I see veterans today who are,
who have been blown up and lost limbs and have been in similar difficult
situations and they are making,
they're doing fantastic because they've started organizations.
We're a leading organizations or deeply involved in organizations that are
helping fellow veterans.
And there it is.
It's like this.
It's like this miracle you sit out to help somebody else and all of a sudden
your problems just seem to melt away.
So if you're struggling right now,
you can reach out to me,
Facebook,
Twitter,
whatever.
Just share your story,
connect and then find a way to help someone else in do it in a way that you're
passionate about.
Man,
I mean I,
I'm passionate about raising my two boys into the next generation of warriors.
I'm,
I'm passionate about,
I mean,
first look around at the spineless coward that society is raising today,
who is raising the next generation of warriors to keep America the greatest
country on the planet.
This generation that says that everybody gets a trophy,
that you get a fricking graduation certificate when you graduate from first
grade.
That's bullshit.
All right,
so get a piece of coal and a kick in the ass.
That's right.
You get something when you earn something and so raising my boys into hard young
men to become gentlemen,
strong warriors,
men of character who will,
who will have a spine and stand for something.
That's what we need to do and those are guys who have been to combat and serve
in our military.
You know how to do that.
You don't have kids find that.
We get involved in local high school,
maybe a local middle school and said be a role model and set an example for some
young boys to be the next generation of bad ass American warriors who will stand
for and protect this country and protect liberty as something to get pretty
excited when I get passionate about that.
Yeah.
That's something that everybody needs to get passionate about.
And like you said,
especially the veterans that
that no one understand that.
And they know and understand and appreciate what real freedom is.
That's right.
Well I think that's
all we've got for tonight.
Did you have any closing comments?
I think you just about summed up
well first and foremost,
Andrew,
thanks for your service.
Thank you for answering the nation's call and I appreciate what you did for me
and what you did for the teams.
Thanks for coming on the podcast and sharing your lessons learned not only about
combat but about what comes after combat.
And for those of you out there listening to the podcast and you want to keep
listening to the podcast,
you want to support the podcast,
my brother Echo Charles is going to tell you how to do that
before I tell you,
actually I have a question way light hearted question compared to,
so when you go into the mortgage industry yeah.
And you know there's other people in the office as well.
Like what did they think about,
did they know,
you know,
your,
your past.
They find out,
you know,
but it's hard to write because in the seal teams we have,
we have a quiet professionalism.
And so one of the things that I've struggled with is,
you know,
look,
I'm certainly proud of my service,
but I don't want to use my service.
And My background in the seal team does a way to advertise and they are main,
there are douchebags in the mortgage business who prey on military and,
and
they've got some great fancy marketing,
but their heart's not in the right place.
So relationships little by little it,
it sneaks out and it's fine if other people know.
But no,
I don't walk in there and tell people that,
hey,
I'm a navy seal.
I mean,
style.
He was just on it.
And I don't know why.
We've never talked about this before.
I've never talked to before,
but like anyone that actually calls themselves a navy seal is like suspect.
You go,
hey,
how's it going?
I'm an EVC.
All right.
It wasn't easy on it.
Just so like you can tell me that you're going,
wait a second,
what's this guy's deal from them?
Right.
No.
Right,
no,
right,
exactly.
But like you,
like,
okay,
Jocko walks in,
we meet Jocko [inaudible] for example,
and he's,
you know,
whatever,
he's Jocko,
we're going to be kind of like,
Hey,
are you a navy seal?
Kind of thing.
But you,
you're kind of like an everyday guy.
I kind of feel,
so you're like,
kind of like the guy in the movie who they show him working or whatever,
and it flashes back to his past and he's kind of the superhero,
you know,
you're like one of those kind of guys.
Do they like,
do you think that they looked at you like that?
Like,
Oh yeah,
you're just,
you know,
our guy,
coworkers kind of thing.
But,
and then maybe one guy heard a rumor,
a,
this guy is,
you know,
this,
the hardened warrior in there.
The other guy's like,
no,
he's no way.
Look at that.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Um,
and that's how I prefer it.
I mean,
I'd rather be,
oh,
they're not knowing.
Yeah.
I'd rather be in the shadow.
I mean,
because look,
here's the deal.
None of us do this for accolade.
None of us do this for the look at me and the guys who advertise,
it's like Jack was saying,
they're suspect because they probably didn't really do it,
you know?
Um,
but I'd say probably one of the best compliments I probably ever got was I heard
about a conversation that happened when I wasn't there and this guy was like,
hey,
yeah,
did you know that guy's a navy seal?
And the other person said,
no,
we don't.
When it guys,
he's so nice.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I'd rather be,
I'd rather be stuff like that.
So you know,
what makes it even more interesting is again,
we'll use Jocko as an example.
If Jocko kind of walks in a room and guys,
you know,
let's say a trouble maker guy.
Yeah.
There you can look at and be like,
I dunno Vaughn,
I started even being with this day.
It's big.
You may or may not have been a,
you know,
a team die,
but then you,
you don't have that to look at you.
Right.
What'd he said?
Not only what you say and you know what you did too though.
To me that makes it even more about,
that's all you need really.
So it makes it that much more interesting to me.
You know,
and it's great,
right?
Because you know what,
a lot of times
I would say more often than not when we,
if we were out as a platoon,
guys would actually want to start a fight with a guy that looks like Jocko
because they're,
they're looking to like test themselves.
Whereas like guys,
I mean that would be a massive miscalculation.
Like really end of life event extinction event kind of decision to be,
not to counter.
I know exactly what you're saying,
but like the facts are people don't mess with me when I'm out in public.
Yeah,
they just don't.
But I know exactly what you're talking about.
It's always some big guy.
The tall guy gets somebody coming up to him.
And uh,
and actually,
you know,
you and I talked about this for those
of you on the podcast and you can't,
you know,
that are listening.
Andrew doesn't look like stereotypical seal.
He's 155 pounds.
He's,
what are you,
how tall are you?
Five,
seven,
five,
seven.
Susan,
look,
he's not your stereotype,
not new stereotypical seal looking guy.
Now again that the public would,
that the public would think,
cause I was going to say there is no stereotype and some of the most bad ass
guys are there every size.
But this is something that Andrew said to me one time,
which was,
you know,
he,
basically people see me and what do they think?
They think,
oh,
this guy,
you know,
he's just going to be a knuckle dragger and,
and he's thinks everybody needs to be big giant,
uh,
you know,
head smashers right.
And the fact of the matter is,
what I care about is can you do your job and can you do it well?
Are you tough?
Are you brave?
Can you lead?
And that's why Andrew,
I,
he was like actually surprised.
Like what do you,
when you finally throw,
you know,
he's like,
man,
you know,
I was kind of fought.
You might not like me,
you know,
because,
um,
you know,
smaller and,
and you know,
I don't look like a seal.
And I was like,
Bro,
it's not about how,
what you look like,
it's about how you act and can you do this job?
Are you brave?
Are you going to step up?
Can you lead?
Great example leadership,
right?
Like that's what you,
that's what you,
that was one point is that you focused on what was the capability of the person
on your team,
not what they look like.
And,
and some guys can do that,
right?
They can,
they can go,
well,
you know,
this or that,
but you were like,
hell no.
I mean,
this guy he puts out,
he can get the job done.
He's leading.
So you know how you're kind of like his,
um,
Dalton Yerba watch?
A roadhouse.
Oh,
I remember,
yeah.
When they're like,
Hey,
I thought you'd be bigger.
He's this bad ass bouncer with,
is that a bad comparison?
Will that get me killed?
Neck roll?
Or he does.
He does actually.
Uh,
you know,
look a lot like Patrick Swayze.
Thank you.
I appreciate your,
yeah,
I'd rather remain stealth,
you know,
and,
and use that to my advantage,
you know,
um,
and kind of remain thought as the underdog.
You know,
he won't see me coming.
I remember we were hanging out at your house,
Jack and,
and um,
and Tristan said,
he goes,
Hey,
who would win in a fight?
You were Jocko.
And I was like,
thanks buddy.
Right in front of Jackie.
And I was like,
you gosh.
Mashy later.
And I go,
well,
I'm not stupid enough to start a fight with Jackie.
It'll wait till he's asleep.
Awesome.
I'm glad we're on the same team,
the exam.
But yes,
if you do want to support this podcast,
there are some ways,
if you don't know already,
uh,
we didn't talk about supplementation or many things that would require
supplementation,
but if you're into it on,
it has the best ones,
common knowledge and Oh,
10% off on it.com/jocko 10% off.
If you need info on any of these supplements,
like the literature behind it,
all that stuff.
It's on there extensively.
If you want
10% off,
support yourself,
your wallet as well.
Also,
when you do Amazon shopping,
um,
we have the click through link on our websites,
which supports the podcasts and you know,
when you shop and of course subscribe to the podcast on iTunes and youtube.
Leave a review,
leave a review yet,
let me know what's up.
Yeah,
let us know what's up.
Yeah.
Those reviews are helpful men.
Cause yeah,
like if they're like,
Hey Jocko,
stop saying like,
like all the time.
No,
I don't say it like,
right.
That's why.
That's why,
you know what I mean?
So,
yeah,
there you go.
Um,
but you know,
pref.
Yeah.
It's a little,
yeah.
Leave a review man.
If you're in the mood.
And then,
uh,
of course Jocko story,
you can buy some shirts and mugs,
some rash guards,
some stickers.
Oh,
we have women's coming out in three days.
It'll be out by the time this is out.
It's out.
Yeah.
Women's is out.
Yeah,
no,
sure.
I got say I liked the Krill oil.
I use the Krill and I'm like,
Yup.
And I'm on the um,
like the um,
the,
what's that the true magic that is getting you through the work.
I like it was,
I was like,
well shit,
you're good to go.
I like it.
There's shroom tech is legit as is the Krill Oil Krill oil.
I was telling them last time where I started the Krill oil and cause I was
looking where when I work out I have strong,
you know,
sore joints,
but I do have sore joints when I wake up.
I just never thought about that.
When people say she's sore joints and stuff,
you know,
you just saw all this and my daughter would jump on my back to wake me up.
I got to walk downstairs with his girl on my bat.
Take Krill oil maybe three,
four days later.
No problem.
I can get up.
I'm walking down the stairs easy like noticeably,
you know,
nice oil.
Jump on it.
A uh,
also on Amazon.
Got that,
get some of that Jocko white tea right here.
Tasting good.
You can step up your game with the antioxidants and micro dose of caffeine.
Get you rocking and rolling.
And while you're out there,
just just go ahead and grab yourself a go and grab yourself a copy of extreme
ownership.
The book that me and my brother Leif Babin road,
and if you already have a copy,
that's cool.
Just go ahead and get one for your boss,
man.
Get one for your team,
your mom,
your dad,
whoever,
hardcover,
digital or if you want to hear Lafe and I talking for eight straight hours,
get the audio book because that's what it is.
And also if you want even more,
come out to the extreme ownership monster.
October 20th and 21st in San Diego,
California at a leadership conference.
We'll be breaking down the fundamental principles of combat leadership and
teaching and talking about how to employ them on the battlefield in business,
in life.
So registered and we'll see you there,
Andrew.
Paul is going to be there by the way.
All Day.
I'll be there with echo.
Charles is going to be there by the way.
We're gonna be getting after it.
So come on out.
And as always,
if you want to keep kicking it with Echo Charles and with me,
we're all up in the inner webs,
Twitter,
Instagram,
and even that Facebooky were there.
Echo is at echo.
Charles,
I am at jockowillink and if you want to get Andrew Paul,
go the Andrew Paul,
the Andrew M.
Paul is that on Twitter?
On Twitter,
the Andrew and Paul.
So if you want to get the Andrew and Paul and you can hit him up.
Facebook,
I'm on Facebook.
Andrew Paul veteran advocate.
Well there you go.
Boom,
boom.
Awesome.
And uh,
once again,
Andrew,
thank you for coming on.
Thank you.
It means a lot to me to have you on here and I really appreciate you coming on
in.
Now everybody listening,
people in uniform,
people in business suits,
people in coveralls,
people,
everyone.
We talked today about Mikey Monsoor.
I don't want to leave you with this.
Mikey monster was named after Saint Michael.
Okay.
Saint Michael is the war.
Your Archangel that led to heaven's army against Satan.
Saint Michael was known as the principal of the angelic warriors,
and it was seen
as a protector against the darkness.
They didn't the Christian religion specifically in the Anglican and the Catholic
and the Lutheran churches.
September 29th September 29th is known as Michael Mass
or Saint Michael's Day.
And that day,
September 29th,
was the day that our Saint Michael,
Mikey Monsoor
was killed in Iraq,
the city of Ramadi,
sacrificing his life
to save the lives of three of his teammates.
Okay?
Three of his brothers,
three best friends.
And I would ask this,
when September 29th comes around,
remember
right?
I would ask that while you honor the hero and you honor the warrior that Michael
[inaudible] store was,
please
also remember
that Mikey was a person,
okay?
He was a smiling kid.
He was a jokester.
He was it determined man,
a brother,
a son,
or an uncle,
or a friend.
Michael Monster War was a young man
with hopes and plans and aspirations and dreams,
dreams for his future,
okay.
And dreams for his life.
And in that moment of truth,
he gave the mall
all those hopes and all those dreams.
He gave them all
to us.
Remember that?
Yeah.
Under till next time.
[inaudible]
this is echo and Jocko
and my brother Andrew Paul
out.